people across Israel are voting right
now in one of that country's tightest
election races in years Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is fighting to win
his fifth term in office if he wins he
will be on track to become Israel's
longest-serving leader but he faces a
tough challenge from his own former
military chief benny ganz Netanyahu is
touting his close ties with President
Trump on the campaign trail Seth Doane
is in tel-aviv with what's at stake Seth
good morning good morning we are here in
a polling place where people are casting
their ballots in an election that is
very much being seen as a referendum on
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu who
has in many ways put President Trump on
the ballot to voters including the
candidates themselves cast ballots today
determining the future of Israel where
the electorate is increasingly
conservative hawkish and religious
what's on the line here today it shows
the world that we have like a true
democracy and we can make a change here
which a lot of the Middle East doesn't
have well there are 41 parties on the
ballot there's one real decision yes or
no to Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
who's seeking his fourth consecutive
term facing corruption allegations in
the stiff competition from former Army
general any Gant's Netanyahu has
campaigned on his closeness to President
Trump if they only had eight years with
Obama he survived Obama and then he won
the lottery
okay with Trump would trump trump is
basically giving him everything he wants
the u.s. moved its embassy to Jerusalem
and just last month recognized Israeli
sovereignty over the Golan Heights
throughout the campaign Netanyahu has
underlined those diplomatic coos we
asked Netanyahu's chief rival Benny Ganz
about that relationship Netanyahu has
with both President Trump and American
he said he believes relationships
between countries is more important than
that between individual leaders John all
right Seth Doane in Tel Aviv Thank You
Seth